[Musique]
quand est-ce que tu lui as parlé pour la dernière fois
ça fait quelques semaines
maman couronne
maman elle m'a appelé il y a quelques semaines
je pense qu'elle avait peur elle pensait que
quelqu'un
entrait dans la maison
tu sais où tu étais maman je suppose
je suis
sorti qu'est-ce que c'est que j'étais sur la propriété
quand votre grand-père en a hérité
son esprit n'était pas là à la fin
vous ne pouvez pas mettre de couronne dans sa maison elle
ne peut plus vivre seule
elle doit être surveillée
tout va bien  accorde je pensais
que c'était là que
ça arrivait qui que ce soit qui entrait dans la maison
maman qu'est-ce que c'est c'est ici
sous le lit il n'y a rien sous le
lit mec tu vas vérifier pour moi
[Musique]
je suis là pour t'aider maman
je peux  à bientôt
cette maison vous semble inconnue